[Music]
this morning in our pushing the limits
series we introduce you to a group of
young engineers
who invented something life-changing
they entered a high school robotics
challenge to help a little boy
do something we all like to do ride a
bike jamie wax returns to show us
how they did it how'd they do it jamie
i'll tell you gail the team calls itself
3616 phenomena
and no these students didn't just run
alongside the boy's bike holding him
steady
they created a device that allows people
with injured damaged and even missing
legs
to pedal themselves and they got their
inspiration from a little guy who just
doesn't quit riding a bike is hard for
james bouquet
in addition to the typical trials and
tribulations of five-year-old faces
trying to balance on two wheels
james has to do it all with one leg
he was born in houma louisiana missing
bones in his left leg it had to be
amputated
and since then he's navigated his world
with a healthy right
but prosthetic left leg on his bike
the prosthetic gets in the way so he
removes it
and the right leg does all the work but
that's
about to change about 90 minutes
northwest of houma there is a robotics
team made up of high school students
from the lafayette parish school system
i've always said this when everybody was
like hey what do you what's robotics
about
it's like everything you want to learn
at school
that you can actually use in the future
it teaches you work ethic
like how to cooperate with other people
team 3616
phenomena participates in first
a global nonprofit that engages young
people in robotics
including an annual competition our
challenge was to
create a device that can benefit
someone's life through active play and
movement
so then we got together had a round
table discussion
and we decided that we wanted to do
something to help someone in our
community
and that's when a little boy became
their muse
the team got to know james because his
grandmother is a biology teacher
in lafayette one of our mentors told us
that we could
do an innovation and create it to help
someone
james who really wanted to ride a bike
like other kids
so the team got to work and what they
came up with
was a kit that when attached to any bike
assists riders with damaged or
prosthetic legs
sensors along the bike tell a motor when
it's time for a little boost
so this leg it pushes you use the
muscles in
your leg right here but on the
compromised leg
it will once you get to the point where
you need to push ill
the motor will go for you the low speed
assist will go and help you
make that round on the pedal where you
can't make it so it's just giving you a
little assistance on
on the down pedal the idea wasn't to
create an electric
bike there are plenty of those but a
kind of robotic bike assistant for those
who need it to keep both legs involved
in
exercise you have like your very own
robot that was made especially for you
that's got to feel really great
better than two legs better than two
legs
james hasn't yet tried out the kit it's
still just a prototype
but he looks forward to the day when he
can ride just like other kids
his age then you get to be special then
you get to be special
special than everybody it's not just
we're doing this to make things to keep
that
in mind that you're helping a person
you're helping a little boy you're
helping
people with lives and stories to tell
you open the door you welcome people in
you help them
and i think it it will come back to help
you in the long run
i think james is specialer than everyone
36-16 phenomena didn't win the first
competition but that doesn't matter
these kids are seeking a patent for
their invention and plan to market it
they've always
already developed a business plan and
have consulted with a prosthetics
company a
special group of people what a
difference for that one little
boy i'm special than everyone now better
than two ways
yeah yeah and shout out to the lafayette
parish school
kids i mean the fact that they would do
something like this for someone in their
community i mean i wasn't doing that
when i was in high school i don't know
about you all but
i was you know this is this entire
program
is a success story for public education
it's fantastic i'm proud that it's in my
home state
it's in the birthplace of our david
begno and my wife yeah my mama's family
the rashoos and the simones
well i made an uh apron in home
economics
those guys are really good thank you
that was a great story
thank you very much jamie